you have the chance to go viral your
chances of going viral go up the more
videos you post what if it actually
could be better for you to not go viral
for a while I feel like an old guy in
the crater economy now I'm coming up on
my 39th birthday 15 years on YouTube but
it's giving me a unique perspective a
lot of the OG is on the platform they're
not here anymore I've seen countless
family vloggers get divorced and I'm not
coming from a judgmental standpoint I am
coming from an observational standpoint
why because there's something about
Timeless wisdom from the Bible that
suggests that slow and steady growth is
better than 15 minutes of fame Proverbs
20 21 says an inheritance gained too
early in life will not be blessed in the
end